I'm so visual aids to be our backstage
with Kane Brown you are about to hit the
stage to rehearse for the ACMs
tell me what's going through your mind
oh no no I might get up there and man
Clete hadn't actually sang the song
since we recorded it so that's more what
I'm worried about than anything but I'm
gonna kill it exciting no to hit the
stage for the first time with Khalid
tell me about how this collaboration
came together i'm kalique came to me
actually on my wedding day I was getting
ready for my wedding and he asked me if
I wanted to get on a song with him so it
was like I got two surprises and one day
I need more information on how this was
your wedding day what happened he was
there no he's texting me it was after
the day after the AMAs and you were like
Kate honey I gotta take this
it's Khalid yeah well luckily she was
getting ready so be like looking at each
other okay we are so excited about that
now you are also nominated this year
congratulations now what I want to know
is ask somebody who's kind of come up in
the industry and in sort of the
new-school way you know through social
media and through really grassroots what
do institutions like this mean to you
what's that recognition mean to you it's
just an honor you know it's like this is
all the country music fans watch this or
your name just to go up there's a
nomination it's that you feel like
you've done you've done something that
you're so I'm just excited to be out
there just be recognized and you are of
course no stranger to blurring lines
between genres but I would say even your
fans were probably surprised to hear you
singing in Spanish with Becky G tell me
why it was important to you to do that
song in that way ah this is another cool
way to get out there in front of
different fans it was awesome because I
got to challenge myself and I luckily my
photographers from Spain so he taught me
everything and I wrote it as close to
English as possible to pronounce it but
it's awesome like I keep getting tags
and videos from like Germany or there
listening to him stuff for like my music
wouldn't usually reach
now you're good as you video is out now
are you fan if this is us
honestly I've watched maybe three to
four episodes but I love Loni though how
did you and Lonnie connect I actually
connected to my manager and everybody
the first time we met he was like like
he couldn't breathe I don't know if it
was acting or what but he's cool like he
was nervous or what yeah he was like I
need a minute I was like so I gave him a
second it came back in now what do you
and Caitlin been binge watch TV is there
anything that you guys are obsessed with
oh we did the TV show good girls
actually like that you've been married
about six months now congratulations
tell me what that little piece of paper
means to you I don't know honestly the
paper don't mean anything to me says she
does she's my best friend
and I wouldn't even need the paper would
be together for the rest of my life dads
getting married change anything has it
had an impact on your relationship I
love my ring I never take my ring I mean
I would I would load it feels the rubber
ring but it's just I don't know it feels
like just mean something to you it's
weighty and and for the first year I
would say you oh you always feel it on
there right oh yeah Wow honestly I don't
feel it anymore but I know it's there
and like if I get nervous like I always
touch it and then that was one time I
lost it in the airport I was scared like
I lost a part of me I was gonna ask if
you ever have that moment of panic
you're like this salon
yeah at one time I wanted to show you
the picture that you posted from the
Houston Rodeo do you know what I'm
talking about on your Instagram oh me
okay yeah tell me what that moment means
to you when you look back on it because
it's such a moving photo yeah they just
told me my silence four times platinum
which was awesome feeling and then just
to hear everybody singing it back it was
crazy
and I got the experience to bring her up
on the phone I mean up on the stage with
me
so just awesome she was crying and I got
the holder and cool I have to shout out
one other Instagram video that you
posted on Valentine's Day with all of
those roses going through the house are
you like a grand gesture kind of guy no
that was like a 1 a lot of times
anything I bought out the road store I
was honestly doing other guys a favor
in case they forgot to buy their girls
roses I could say the store was out of
it would you say that's the craziest or
biggest thing that you've done for love
or do you have another story for me I
feel like my proposal was the best yeah
I asked her I asked her to marry me
during a medieval horror movie it must
be special to you guys no it wasn't it
was cool because I sent her home for
Easter because she was saying her she's
from Pennsylvania and her family she
never gets to see her family she wanted
to spend Easter with her family had
shows so I sent her to Pennsylvania she
was upset that I wasn't with her and I
pulled my tour bus up to her house and
then I proposed to her once I got there
so then I got to spend Easter with her
as well so one O'Kane this is why we
love you thank you so much good luck
snake good luck on Sunday
[Music]